ابدا من المغرب والكشف عن البرنامج
الاستثماري الاخضر الجديد لمجموعه المكتبه
الشريفه
يرتكز على الرفع من قدرات انتاج الاسمده
مع الالتزام بتحقيق الحيض الكربوني قبل
عام 2040 وذلك من خلال الاعتماد على
الامكانات الفريده من الطاقه المتجدده ومن
خلال الاستثمار في الطاقه الشمسيه والطاقه
الريحيه
ولمزيد من التفاصيل حول هذا الموضوع وتنضم
الينا من مدينه الدار البيضاء السيده حنان
مرشد المديره تنفيذيه للتنميه المستدامه
في مجموعه المكتب الشريف للفوسفات انا
ومرحبا بك سيدتي بدايه ما هي اهم المحاور
الكبرى لهذا البرنامج الاستثماري وما هي
اهميته في تطوير مجموعه المكتب الشريف
للفوسفات وتطوير ايضا الاقتصاد المغربي
شكرا جزيلا شكرا للاستضافه اولا لابد ان
نشير الى هذا لان هذا البرنامج لاستثماري
ياتي من اجل تكميل برنامج الاستثماري
الاول الذي اطلقه المجمع الشريف المسلسل
سنه 2012 فقط
سنه 2040 وبالتالي هناك استثمار في الطاقه
الشمسيه الطاقه الريحيه همم تعقدات
الانتاج ديال
المناجم ديالنا ديال المنشات الصناعيه
لصناعه الاسمده والى غير ذلك او كذلك مياه
الغير الاعتياديه تحليه المياه البحر
لاستعمالها في الري وفي الماء الصالح
للشرب
ستلعب القدرات المحليه للبحث العلمي
والابتكار دور في انجاح هذا البرنامج
الاستثماري الجديده
هي مكون من جد اساسي وجيد مهم لترجمات هذا
البرنامج على الواقع
فاتمد المجمع السادس الفوسفات على قدره
البحث والتطوير لجامعه محمد السادس
الاختصاصات التقنيه التي توفر التقنيات
الصناعيه والرقميه الجديده وذلك لتطويل
الخبره في التقنيات الجديده
للتخصيب
الارض بطريقه
تاثير الفلاحه على البيئه الى غير ذلك من
اجل ذلك تم الانتاج العديد من مرض البحث
المتخصصه داخل جامعه محمد السادس
مركز الطاقه الخضراء
والهندسه
عناصر مكونه من البطاريات الفستان
الحديد الى
حتى تصل الى مكون صناعي على الواقع
وكذلك مكون الاساسي اللي هو النسيج
الصناعي الوطني الذي لا يجب الاعتماد عليه
من اجل الوصول لهذا الطموح لاجل ذلك فنحن
سنواكب اكثر من 600 مقاوله صناعيه صغرى
ومتوسطه انجح هذا البرنامج من مدينه الدار
البيضاء احنا المرشد شكرا جزيلا لك
المديره التنفيذيه للتنميه المستدامه
لمجموعه المكتبه الشريف للفوس